I pay the fairy godmother it's quite
tricky because I mean I it's sort of
iconic in that everyone knows what a
fairy godmother is but there wasn't
particularly I suddenly thought what
does she look like my little five year
old said you can't play a fairy
godmother because you don't white hair
you look terrible Dwight hair I was
thinking one earth is she talking about
and then I realized that she was talking
about this the animated version and
there's a sort of in in the animated
version she's about six of years old and
I thought oh god great I vomit that old
already but visually there isn't like a
consistent image but I knew anyway there
were lots of possibilities it is
basically fun but it's kind of a bit
like reinventing the wheel in that you
think like well hang on how did she get
from why does she choose a pumpkin to
you know make a carriage and why does
she get the where'd she get the mice and
why should it be a pumpkin and I think I
originally came up with the idea which
I'm not sure if it was in the script but
first was that she might be not a
totally efficient fairy godmother and
she's highly stressed because at the
time there's a time issue they're late
for the ball and she's also incredibly
old so she's not quite with it mentally
and she's so maybe she's not the totally
efficient at her with her magic so the
pumpkin I thought well maybe it's an
accident maybe she didn't mean it to be
a pump maybe she originally wanted it to
be something else so that's when you'll
see what have we I think originally
asked for a watermelon but it's some she
takes things and then transforms things
she's a bit like a cook I mean I start
off as an old lady there's an old beggar
woman and it took them longer to make me
look like the fairy godmother in her
young looks and it took to make me look
old it took me four hours to look about
a thousand years old
it takes me about five hours to look
like fairy godmother Lily was great and
here's of course there's a fairy
godmother you have to love the person
that you're you know your ward or your
fairy goddaughter so she is and she's
she's very easy to love and she's
adorable and she's got a natural charm
and grace and a sort of timeless
and and she's a really really brilliant
actress so my costume is a big costume
it's possibly the biggest costume I've
had to ever wear it's um it's massive
white silvery I'm about four foot wide
I've got a huge
I've got wings that was initially in
fact they weren't gonna give me wings
and I said to Sandy like I am a fairy
you know every five-year-olds gonna go
like not believe I'm a fairy if I don't
have wings and I light up that's my
thing
you